I have some stunning video for you today
this is a literal deep platforming
someone was pushed off of the platform
from which they were speaking a literal
platform of stage I'm talking about a
father Marcelo Rossi preaching at a
retreat in Sao Paulo Brazil he is an
extremely anti-gay priest very very
homophobic a couple of examples back in
1998 he said quote a lot of ideas will
change the day homosexuality is proven
to be an illness
in 2014 he said quote sex between men
causes pain if something causes pain it
can't be a good thing interesting I
wonder if he would apply that to aerobic
exercise as well or maybe there's a
different standard applied there so in
any case Marcelo Rossi is preaching and
the initial this is an important thing
to mention the initial reports about
this were that he was preaching about
how fat women don't go to heaven at the
moment that a woman ran on stage and
pushed him off we've since learned that
that appears not to be the case I'm
gonna play the video here for you you
will see a woman run on stage and shove
him off this is the mother of a
three-year-old that was at the retreat
and it appears that this is really a
case of someone suffering from mental
health issues
let's take a look yes no mines because
this picadors fracas is as most pc
version a facility please paris lv
paradise
[Applause]
so again the controversy was that it was
initially claimed that the the priest
was preaching about how fat women can't
go to heaven at the time that the woman
ran onstage and pushed him off the
implication was it was a direct response
to the vile nature of what he was saying
it appears that that was not the case he
was reportedly preaching about how his
hands belong to Jesus which may be just
as kooky in the eyes of non-believers as
anything else that he might have been
saying but it was not fat women can't go
to heaven and then it seems that this
really was more about a mentally ill
person sadly than anything else although
this guy is horrific aliy anti-gay and
any opportunity to point out that there
are these sort of they are established
they are almost like codified homophobes
this is a priest with a following and
regularly speaking to large audiences
about how bad also that you know
anything LGBT related is it's still an
opportunity to mention that this is
going on I have to be very clear that
I'm against violence like this I'm
against this priest I'm against his
ideas I'm also against homophobia but I
don't know that we really achieve much
by shoving the guy off the stage if it
was indeed just a mentally ill person
who was acting in a way that was
dissociated from sort of common sense
and rational thinking then that's what
it was if it was an act against the
speech of the priest I don't believe
that this is how those who are in favor
of LGBT rights those who are defenders
of all of the things that we on the Left
defend I don't think we achieve our
goals with this type of action if you
disagree though let me know I know there
is a sliver of our audience that has
more of a tendency towards using
physical violence to try to achieve
political goals and I'm open to hearing
from everybody make sure you're
following me on Instagram at David
Pakman you can also follow the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show if you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire
to free access to Skillshare when you
click the link underneath this video
skill share is a vibrant online learning
community offering more than 25,000
video classes on just about anything you
can think of get better at playing an
instrument learn to use Photoshop how to
edit videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video